Noah Williams: Today’s focus: observability for API timeouts.
Samira López: Any blockers from last time?
Jordan Patel: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Noah Williams: I think we split observability for API timeouts into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: I propose we split observability for API timeouts into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on observability for API timeouts; ship a thin slice.
Samira López: We should add a feature flag on observability for API timeouts.
Jordan Patel: My take is we split observability for API timeouts into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Risk: flaky tests for observability for API timeouts.
Noah Williams: From design side, We might need a migration.
Samira López: I propose we split observability for API timeouts into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Infra-wise, We might need a migration.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on observability for API timeouts; start with a spike.
Avery Kim: I think we split observability for API timeouts into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on observability for API timeouts; parallelize testing.
Priya Singh: Action: book design review.
Riley Chen: From QA perspective, We might need a migration.
Riley Chen: Risk: flaky tests for observability for API timeouts.
Jordan Patel: We should add a feature flag on observability for API timeouts.
Priya Singh: From design side, We might need a migration.
Avery Kim: Risk: flaky tests for observability for API timeouts.
Samira López: My take is we split observability for API timeouts into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on observability for API timeouts; start with a spike.
Samira López: Risk: data migration for observability for API timeouts.
Jordan Patel: Risk: scope creep for observability for API timeouts.
Samira López: Risk: flaky tests for observability for API timeouts.
Priya Singh: I propose we split observability for API timeouts into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Risk: data migration for observability for API timeouts.
Avery Kim: Risk: data migration for observability for API timeouts.
Priya Singh: Action: write migration.
Samira López: My take is we split observability for API timeouts into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Infra-wise, Security review is likely.
Priya Singh: Risk: data migration for observability for API timeouts.
Jordan Patel: I think we split observability for API timeouts into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: Risk: flaky tests for observability for API timeouts.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on observability for API timeouts; ship a thin slice.
Jordan Patel: Action: write migration.
Jordan Patel: Risk: data migration for observability for API timeouts.
Samira López: Risk: data migration for observability for API timeouts.
Riley Chen: Risk: flaky tests for observability for API timeouts.
Priya Singh: From QA perspective, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on observability for API timeouts; parallelize testing.
Jordan Patel: Let’s capture action items clearly on observability for API timeouts.
Jordan Patel: Any risks we’re missing? on observability for API timeouts.
Noah Williams: Risk: flaky tests for observability for API timeouts.
Riley Chen: I think we split observability for API timeouts into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Any risks we’re missing? on observability for API timeouts.
Jordan Patel: Okay, who can take ownership?
Avery Kim: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Jordan Patel: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.